he's on a park but I knew her before I
that I knew her husband Tom Segura and I
knew her way before I think I knew it
before now okay
true story yeah I don't know if you're
you probably don't remember the very
first time I ever did stand-up comedy it
was in the belly room
I was 26 years old how many years goes
out in 42 anyways I was I I started I
woke up that morning I was gonna do
stamp for the first time and I had
diarrhea all day long in the greenroom
yeah yeah at the comic store upstairs in
the belly yeah and I was taking shits
coming back taking and in-between
[ __ ] yeah in walks Bobby Lee into
the bathroom no and I was like oh I know
that guy like the guy's famous right and
then you sit down next to me and I was
so nervous and I was like shaking and
sweating and you just start talking to
me like hey what's up what are you doing
what you got what's going on boy I was
so nervous I couldn't talk to you oh
really
and I was like I have to [ __ ] and I told
you that yeah yeah you were cool and
that was the first time I met you
really the diarrhea have to do with your
nervousness yes I had diarrhea for the
first six years of doing Stan I was so
skinny yeah yeah back in my early
footage you get diarrhea whenever you're
nervous in general yes Wow to this day
if I'm like taping a special or so right
I will [ __ ] my brains out right before
and then I know it's gonna be a good
show Wow yeah yeah I don't care like now
I mean you know you probably sleep until
you go up on stage yeah I mean I sleep I
slept till 2:00 1:30 today how if you
hadn't come dog don't 4:30 if I want to
say one thing about you though before we
even get into whatever it is what are
you doing last night I saw you years ago
maybe five or six years ago at the Ice
House you were in the Annex yeah and I
was doing the other room and I walked
into your room to watch him and I
literally I thought it was with I go
that could be one of the strongest
comics oh because you do know honors I'm
being honest
Eric Griffin last week no I didn't I
know I was getting the opposite I got
you this I was there oh yeah but no I
don't say that to other people number
one I appreciate and number two I did
say it to her when she said it was when
we were dating so it had to be less than
five years ago that and then I really do
believe that and also on here's another
tidbit about you that I like is that
you've been known to [ __ ] gooks higher
or lower
I don't what do you mean Chinese Chinese
well them so he's a top top now oh you
topped off taiwan taiwan is a very like
you know very yeah progressive yeah
that's well there's a difference between
taiwanese and like mainland Oh huge it's
like a Manhattan in these whites college
buildings the street where they grew up
these whites just trees just trees and
just dirt yeah yeah [ __ ] you they're
very progressive and just so I get Asian
bangin points yeah it wasn't just I was
banging this guy I lived with a Chinese
guy we were gonna get married I'm down
for the cause bro yeah that's how low
you were in your life he was the best he
really sweet all right not as sweet as
my husband yeah yeah what's his name
again and weird he's a real person um no
actually I you know he went on to become
a very successful lawyer as I was
starting to become a comedian so it was
like he was gonna take me to his lawyer
dinners and be like hey guys look at
make fart sounds Marv
do you I mean good it wasn't a good man
really did you meet him when you were
how'd you meet him
college yeah so he saw you to ring your
MTV days yeah yeah he knew me before and
then after because I took a semester off
to do that in the night came back to
school
[Music]